when you're talking about left-wing like
you know people go to journalism school
they come out they know they're supposed
to be looking for objective truths they
know what the job is supposed to be
right the definition of what a
journalist is and then they go to work
for liberal media and they become
puppets well
first of all remember most journalists
are liberal i think there's a stat out
there tyler i don't know it's like very
high number the number of journalists
that actually are
democrats or liberal versus conservative
the percentage is astounding right so by
nature now why is that because they go
through academia they come out they go
through those politics courses and those
journalism courses taught by people who
espouse liberal ideologies so they
already come out of the gate liberal by
and large let me know if you have that
you can interrupt me if you get it
um
so they come out liberal right from
school they start that way
and then i have to be honest with you
the second part of this question is not
i know you said cnn msnbc because i know
that leads me to believe that you're
conservative
so i'm going to just burst this bubble a
little bit and just tell you it's not
just liberal media
it's
media okay
every single one of these institutions
that you go to
in many cases you're expected to be a
puppet now that doesn't mean you can't
share your opinion
that doesn't mean you can't voice your
opinion but it does mean that you can
step out of bounds and it's not cool in
other words your opinion is great if it
falls within these borders
here you work for cnn msnbc i'm going to
put fox on there i'm going to put
anywhere anywhere newsmap i don't care
i haven't worked at newsmax so it's hard
for me to say but wait
here your opinion
yeah but what if mine's over here
that's touching a topic we're not gonna
nope can't go over there
okay so what if i fall over here nope
stay in the zone
okay so it gives the mirage
of diversity of thought it gives the
mirage of different people debating
different topics and feeling differently
why because this is the zone and maybe i
fall here and you fall here and somebody
else falls here so within the zone we
differ
but no one's saying this
advertisers can't have that
and no one's touching this topic nope
nope big pharma can't have that
so you see what i'm saying there's a lot
that goes on behind the scenes that you
don't realize and the reason people
become puppets is i'll tell you they
want to keep their jobs
they want to earn a living
they make big fat paychecks sometimes
and get book deals and all sorts of
things
and it's worth it to them right in the
same way that a lot of people got the
vaccine
while they were screaming from the
rooftops about freedom
they went and decided i work for a big
television network and have a big
microphone and i can't work in new york
without a vaccine so here you go and
then i'll scream about freedom on tv but
i really just do as i'm told okay
and that's the honest to god truth
there's too much of that in media
because people who are drawn to media in
large part want to be famous
they want to be famous they want to be
on screen above all else
okay you know how many times i told you
that i would sit on a set and somebody
would be like donald trump blah blah
blah blah blah and he's gonna win and he
really that blah blah blah and then
cameras go off and this is what you see
that's such i mean that [ __ ] guy's
not gonna win
and i would be like
that's not me
y'all know it
got fired
just saying that's not me
so just know and don't see though i
appreciate the question but don't only
see it through that lens it's not just
the media avenues you don't like
sometimes it's also some of the ones you
do like it's a problem in media at large
who's been they've been bought and sold
in many respects and it's sad which is
why the podcasting world is booming
because we just talk
we're just like whatever
okay uh 2013 washington post 7.1 percent
of journalists uh
reported as republican
7.1
20 and this is a survey they run every
10 years so in 2002 it was 18
28 identified as democrat 50.2
identified as independent which is up
from 32 in 2002. so i imagine they'll
run this study again soon it's every
time it usually means
democrat right
left right means left um the only people
that will call themselves independent
that lean right are people who sometimes
no actually no not in modern world i was
going to say sometimes conservatives who
don't want that label republican because
they feel like the republican party
betrayed them like they're not
conservative enough but those people
won't say independent they'll say
conservative independent is usually
someone who leans left but doesn't
ascribe to the crazy on the democrat
side like they're not gonna they don't
want to be looped in with aoc but they
also are you know
democrats if you like the short clip you
can catch another one here or you can
catch the full episode right here
[Music]